"Leo tiene $4,522.08 en su cuenta bancaria.
Deposita otros $875.50, y hace un retiro en
efectivo de $300. ¿Cuánto dinero queda en su
cuenta?" Entonces empieza con 4,522 dólares y
8 centavos, vamos a escribirlo: 4,522 dólares
y 8 centavos, y después deposita, es decir,
suma otros 875 dólares y 50 centavos, entonces
suma 875 dólares y 50 centavos. Acomodaremos de
acuerdo a su valor posicional. Cuando depositas en
una cuenta agregas algo a esa cuenta o, dicho de
otra manera, sumas algo a la cuenta. Entonces,
después de sumar 875 dólares y 50 centavos,
¿cuánto tiene la cuenta? Empezaremos con el
lugar de los centavos, o podemos verlo como
el lugar de las centésimas. Un centavo es 1
centésimo de dólar, 8 + 0 es 8, 0 + 5 = 5;
pongamos justo aquí el punto decimal. 2 + 5 es
7, 2 + 7 es 9, 5 + 8 es 13, ponemos aquí el 3 y
llevamos 1 o reagrupamos el 1, 1 + 4 = 5. Por lo
tanto, después del depósito de 875 dólares y 50
centavos, Leo tiene 5,397 dólares y 58 centavos.
Después hace un retiro en efectivo de 300 dólares,
o saca de la cuenta 300 dólares, entonces
tendremos que restar: Leo hace un retiro en
efectivo de 300 dólares y pondremos algunos ceros
al final, después del punto decimal: 300 dólares
es lo mismo que 300 dólares y 0 centavos. Y ahora
podemos restar: 8 - 0 es 8, 5 - 0 = 5, pongamos
justo aquí nuestro punto decimal, 7 - 0 es
7, 9 - 0 = 9, 3 - 3 es 0, y por último 5
menos nada por aquí es 5. Así que Leo se queda
con 5,097 dólares y 58 centavos en su cuenta.